Speaker 1: Here's an interesting story. There is
a group of fed up Republicans in Texas that are
buying billboards that say Trump lost. These
are Republicans who don't like the Big Lie
Republicans, apparently. Former President Donald
Trump has been pushing for audits, even in states
where he won. But some anti-Trump Republicans
are putting their foot down in Texas. My San
Antonio reports that three billboards have sprung
up in San Antonio that bluntly declare Trump lost.
While at the same time demanding no more audits
of the 2020 election in their state. Remember that
Republican Gov. Greg Abbott announced, We're going
to audit four counties or something like that.
Remember, Trump won Texas, but lost overall.
According to My San Antonio, the billboards
are being sponsored by an organization called
Republicans for Voting Rights, spending a quarter
of a million dollars to pay for billboards
in Texas, Georgia, Florida, Pennsylvania,
Michigan, Virginia, Wisconsin and Arizona. A Trump
backed audit in Arizona conducted over the summer
failed to prove that Trump won the state and in
fact gave Joe Biden more votes. Despite this,
Trump continues to push for more audits in that I
don't want to spend a lot of time on this story,
but imagine needing huge signs to tell
you something as obvious as Trump lost.
But they do, and Republicans and a lot of these
states, including Texas, because there's a lot of
Republicans. Some of these other states, because
people, Republicans in those states have become
convinced that Trump actually won those states,
even though he didn't. Lots of the Republicans,
I think it's important to mention disavow this one
fairy tale. There are there are tens of millions,
I would estimate of Republicans who disavow
the fairy tale that Trump actually won,
but they fully believe other Republican fairy
tales they believe trickle down economic works.
They believe the national debt should be thought
of just like household debt. And so while you know
you give credit where credit is due, there
are some Republicans like Liz Cheney, who
don't believe the fairy tale that Trump won. They
believe many other fairy tales that are basically
just as destructive to the United States. Also,
remember that lots of Republicans don't literally
believe Trump won. They see saying that Trump
won as a sort of loyalty test a loyalty oath
in a war that they see themselves as fighting. So
for some of these Republicans that might see these
billboards telling them Trump lost doesn't change
their view on the fact it's not even an empirical
argument for them. It just makes them see you as
the enemy. And to these Republicans who continue
to say Trump won. Republicans willing to admit
that Trump didn't win are actually the enemy. So,
you know, but Republicans can spend money doing
whatever they want. In this case, it's, I guess,
trying to convince other Republicans Trump
didn't really win. Many of those Republicans
sort of already know that there are some
Republicans who believe literally Trump
won. But for many of them, it's just this is
what I say to demonstrate that I'm on the team,
that I'm doing the right things and that I'm
playing the role I'm supposed to play. Send me
your thoughts. We're going to take a quick break,
and we'll be back with much more right after this